And the last bit of context that I want to add at
this point is to display the year being shown so
that as it animates through, we know what World Cup we're actually looking at.
Let's use the same code we used in our chart example and
append an h2 tag to the top of our chart and use some CSS to center it.
And if we refresh the page here,
we can see we now have a static title, World Cup, and the animation still works.
But let's go back and make this title dynamic.
And now in our update function that's going to get run for every year.
We can select our h2 tag and change it's text to represent the World Cup and
the year variable that we're updating.
Going back to our browser, we can see here the year properly animates and
we have much more context as to what we're looking at as the map changes.
And now we have a link between what year we're actually visualizing,
the attendance, how it's changed from one year to the next
through the animation, but
also how it's changed depending on which country's hosting the game.
And how the geographic spread of participating countries changes from
one year to the next, and one host country to the next.
And we're just about done with our animation, and have
a great author driven narrative that represents the stem of our martini glass.
Before we leave this animation, I just want to touch on D3 transitions, which
would make any changes to our graphic much smoother and aesthetically pleasing.